For this session.
I would like to first welcome you to this
session on Precision Liver Cancer Care Across the Continuum, From
Prevention to Therapy.
My name is Valerie Chiu from Duke-NUS Medical School,
and the chair for this session. It's a great honor and pleasure to be
chairing this session and bringing together different
perspectives from across Asia, Europe, and
the United States. And what we'd like to call this session as the East
Meet West Perspectives on Liver Cancer Care.
HCC remain one of the leading causes of cancer-related
death worldwide,
and it is even predicted to increase by more than
55% by the year 2040.
Despite significant improvement in terms of cancer
care, especially with the advancement in immunotherapy,
the outcome remain highly valuable.
So we really have a key challenge here because we believe HCC
is not a single disease.
And it is really a highly heterogeneous cancer, which is
very hard to treat,
and the cancer itself is shaped not only by the tumor intrinsic
biology, but also by the underlying liver disease
that is very heterogeneous in nature.
And it also has the different immune contexts.
And increasingly, we are seeing more and more metabolic-related liver
disease that is causing this cancer.
So what this means is that the one size fits all
approaches are no longer sufficient to treat liver cancer.
Instead, we are entering into an era where precision
medicine is becoming more and more important.
And this will span across the full disease continuum
from identifying who is at risk, to understanding the
biology and the mechanism, and finally, to tailor the
precision medicine to treat our patients.
And today's session is structured exactly to address this.
We will begin first upstream with precision prevention
by our first speaker, Professor Yujin Hosoda, who will
focus on biomarkers-guided precision prevention of
HCC.
And then we'll move on to understanding the mechanism
using advanced omics technology delivered by myself.
And finally, we will end with the third speaker, who will talk about
clinical integration and personalized care for liver cancer
patients by Dr. Manon Aller.
So with that, I think without further ado, we all believe that this is
an important disease that we need to discuss herein.
So we will begin with our first speaker, Professor Yujin
Hosoda. Professor Hosoda is a clinician scientist
and a professor of internal medicine, Director of Liver Tumor
Translational Research, Co-director of Liver Cancer SPOR
Program at University of Texas Southwestern Medical
Center. So many titles there. And his work has been
instrumental, really,
in defining the molecular risk factors or signature for liver
cancer, as you may all well known about this Hosoda
et al. gene signature. So
Professor Hosoda, please. Thank you.
Thanks so much for having me and a very kind introduction, Professor
Chiu. So let me start with
the prevention things.
I will talk about our ongoing works attempting
to introduce a precision prevention strategy for HCC
using the biomarker, and I'd love to hear your feedback and
advice.
My disclosure.
So let me start from this, from a recent Lancet Commission article
showing the overall survival change
after the surgical treatment of HCC patients over the past six
decades, starting from the oldest era,
shown at the bottom blue line, with a 10-year overall survival
of only 7%, which has been remarkably
improved to nearly 60% in the most recent era, shown at the
top by red line. This is a remarkable change, but
still, this indicate
HCC is not still the curable disease.
This article also noted this gap is attributable to the failure of the
prevention, and three out of five liver cancer cases can
be theoretically preventable, otherwise, the number will be double
by 2050.
So, what kind of preventive intervention we can think about for
HCC? So here I'm showing the natural history of HCC development,
starting from the healthy liver here,
exposed to the risk factor, HBV, HCV, alcohol, and metabolic
disorders, and the liver gradually develop the
accumulating liver fibrosis, chronic inflammation, which
eventually lead to the terminal stage cirrhosis here.
Then cancer starts to arise.
Along with the natural history, we can think about the preventive
intervention at the different levels.
For example, the primary aims to prevent the exposure to the risk factor.
We do HPV vaccination to infants, which is shown to be
very effective to reduce HCC incidence.
Secondary prevention. We do regular HCC screen for early
detection, followed by the curative therapy.
And we know antiviral therapies
significantly reduce HCC incidence, but does not
eliminate the cancer incidence in some patients.
Tertiary prevention kicks in after the initial diagnosis of the cancer.
And what we can do is only recurrence monitoring therapy at this moment, and
we are still waiting for the neoadjuvant adjuvant therapy becomes
available.So in this talk, I will talk about unmet
needs in the secondary prevention, which is a refined screening and the
chemo prevention. And then you will learn about the later stage
treatment of HCC from Professor Cho and Professor Alya
later in this session.
So, first topic, HCC screening.
So this is what we do for the regular HCC screening recommended in the
guidelines. Here is the target population, cirrhosis, and the red
people are indicating the people who will develop cancer during the
irregular screening.
So we do semiannual screening with ultrasound and AFP,
but this recommended protocol is poorly utilized in the
US, representing the US perspective.
So the real utilization rate is less than 25%, which would be much,
much higher in the Asian country like Singapore and Europe.
But this is our real-world capability in the US.
So, this is what we propose to do as a
solution, which is a risk-stratified screening, which is impressed in
the hepatology paper led by Dr. Kanwal,
under the NCI-supported Translational Liver Cancer, or TLC,
consortium. So here's the idea. So you do the risk
prediction upfront and stratify the patients into these risk groups,
high, intermediate, low risk group.
And then tailor the priority and the intensity of the screening modality
like this. For example, for low-risk people, you may apply low-performance
and low-cost test or do nothing.
Intermediate risk, you may stick to the current regular tests,
and the high-risk people may be justifiable to be followed by high-performance and
high-cost tests based on the anticipated higher yield.
And this approach found to be very cost-effective in a simulation
analysis compared to the one-size-fits-all screening and especially risk in
the situation in the US we are facing.
And what kind of risk stratification tools we have?
So we have numbers of clinical variable-based scores that are listed here.
This part shows the five-year AURLC for the risk
prediction. And some of the scores are actually incorporated in the
clinical practice. For example, the PAGE-B score in the middle,
which definitely helps identify high-risk people, especially in the
hepatitis B-infected patients. But still, as you see in the top
part of the bar, there is still the room for the improvement.
That's why many people are working on a biomarker discovery and development using
the molecular information or imaging-based information or
more recently, the histology-based information with the emergence of
digital pathology combined with the deep learning methods, which can be
also utilized for the clinical data or patient-derived electronical
data.
And here, let me show the one example, such a potential HCC
risk biomarker we are working on, which is the HCC risk signature in
the liver tissue, which we call PLS, prognostic liver signature, or
it's a serum protein version, which we call PLS-Sec,
stands for the prognostic liver secretome signature, validated in the
multicenter prospective cohorts in the US.
So here I'm showing the validation in the prospective cohort in the state of
Texas, which enroll more than 2,000 patients, which nicely
stratify the patient according to the risk level, which is
associated with the actual real-world HCC incidents,
which was replicated in a nationwide cohort called heads supported by
NIH NCI
in enrolling the more than 1,300 patients.
So this is a promising finding, and this is a more recent simulation
analysis we published led by my clinical colleague, Amy Stengel,
which we call the precision HCC screening.
So here we are looking at not only the biomarker but also
incorporating patient factors such as patient sex, liver disease,
etiology, severity, and the metabolic status.
And in this exercise, this tailored screening is way more
cost-effective or cost-saving and extending the patient's
survival.
So, with the emergence of AI and IT technology,
we are hopeful to implement this very complicated algorithm
sometime in the near future.
So the second part, chemo prevention.
So, we all know clinical development of preventive,
chemopreventive strategies is very challenging.
So I'm showing the series of failed HCC chemo prevention trials.
The major effort enrolling more than 100 patients,
testing the variety of agents, interferon, COX-2 inhibitor,
a cyclic retinoid, or M2 inhibitor.
So these are well-supported by convincing preclinical
clinical data or retrospective data.
But all
failed to demonstrate clinically appreciable chemopreventive effect.
So these trial, chemo prevention trials are highly demanding,
require large sample size and a longer follow-up time compared to the
typical oncology trial, despite the very
low success rate.
Now you may wonder, are the choice of the targets and agent may be wrong
despite the ample supporting preclinical evidences.
So the question is, which are the clinically relevant chemoprevention targets and
agents?
So in literature, you can see many plausible
chemoprevention targets
around the mechanism of hepatocarcinogenesis.
So we believe the matured hepatocyte is a cell of origin for
HCC transforming into the HCC cell.
With the involvement of multiple cell types, we will hear about
Professor Chu after my talk. There are many,
the anti-protumor immune cells or
immunosuppressive immune cell types.
And also another major cell type is a hepatic stellate cell, which is the liver's
pericytes responsible for the wound-healing response,
which transdifferentiated to the cell phenotype called the myofibroblast,
which is responsible for the production of collagen tissue,
extracellular matrix protein, and which directly or indirectly
influence the process of the transformation.And outside the liver,
we know from the studies, gut dysbiosis transmitting the
signal, and also the systemic adipose tissue affect the
system, the transformation.
And you can also find a series of many potential
compounds and drugs that may inhibit the process as a
possible chemoprevention agent, especially
anti-metabolic disease therapy or anti-obesity therapy may have
a great potential.
However, even if you can come up with a plausible
biology by targeting any of those targets,
one caveat is that plausible biology is not necessarily equal to
clinically meaningful cancer preventive targets.
So you may wonder, what is a reliable molecular readout to
monitor dynamic change in HCC risk level in
response to any of this therapy as a surrogate endpoint in the real-world
patients?
So going back to the well-validated HCC risk biomarker
just showed in the previous slide, we wonder if this biomarker can
serve as such a surrogate endpoint.
And then we ask if this biomarker-based risk level can be modulated by
the therapeutic intervention known to reduce HCC incidence.
For example, anti-HBV drug, which are known to significantly reduce
HCC incidence. And in these 19 patients, we had a
chance to analyze the changes in the biomarker before and after the antivirus
therapy. And these patients all successfully cured the virus.
And this bar plot or waterfall plot, if you will,
y-axis is measuring the change in the biomarker risk level.
And when the bar goes down, that means a reduction in the HCC risk level by the
biomarker, which is seen in roughly 80% of the patients.
And subsequent HCC incidence is significantly correlated with the
change of the biomarker over 20 years of clinical follow-up.
This may be only antiviral therapies.
Statins are also suggested as a potential chemopreventive
agent with association with a significantly lower HCC
incidence in retrospective studies, particularly for lipophilic
but not hydrophilic statin. And when we look at the change of the
biomarker, indeed we see the improvement of the biomarker in
the lipophilic statin users but not the hydrophilic users.
Bariatric surgery is another intervention known to be associated with a
lower HCC incidence. And similarly, we saw
biomarker improvement that is associated with bariatric surgery.
And a more recent drug, anti-obesity drug, GLP-1 receptor
agonist and so forth,
we wonder if it apply to this new class of agents.
And these are the preclinical study done in the animal model, and the four
studies representing the liver disease model by the
diet-based or genetic-based intervention for each of the
heat map representing each of the four model.
In this heat map, orange means induction,
green means suppression. So the left side is a baseline high-risk
status in each of the animal model.
So here in this model, high-risk genes are orange, induced.
Low-risk genes are suppressed, green.
It's a high-risk status, which is completely reverse to the low-risk pattern
with the semaglutide treatment with the varying degree for the other
agents. So with this exercise, we thought
our HCC risk signature modulation can be used as a surrogate endpoint in the
clinical trial.
So we also wonder this signature can be used as a clue to the new
agent to reduce HCC incidence. And this is one of the
example, the risk signature, which compose the two parts.
High-risk genes
representing the activation of several growth factor signaling, inflammatory
signaling, and the low-risk genes representing the bile
acid metabolic functions, representing the healthy hepatocyte function
along with the DNA damage repair-related gene sets.
You can now map onto the liver tissue from the
patient with liver disease. The red spots are the cells
expressing the high-risk genes, and the green is induction of low-risk
genes. And you see the island of the red here, which is completely
overlap with the fibrous tissue in the diseased liver.
You can further deconvolute to the cell types.
And interestingly, we found indeed the high-risk genes are coming from
those stromal cell types or infiltrating immune cells.
On the other hand, low-risk genes are coming from a subset of hepatocytes.
And here's the myofibroblast. And the one pathway, EGF
pathway, which is almost exclusively activated in the
myofibroblast, caught our attention because of this clinical study
led by our long-standing colleague, Dr.
Ken Tanabe of Mass General, published in The JAMA and the Gastro paper,
saying that the SNP in this EGF gene, GLL,
is correlated with higher serum EGF protein level
and association with a higher HCC incidence.
So we thought this is highly likely, this clinical observation is
linked to this liver tissue finding.
So we wanted to test how the therapeutic and the preventive intervention works
in an in vivo model. So here's a rat model, gradually develop
fibrosis, which eventually lead to the cirrhosis, then HCC start to
emerge,
in which we saw the striking induction of the human clinical
risk signature at the very early stage of the disease, even
before the manifestation of histological fibrosis.
And phospho-EGFR, which is an indicator of the EGFR pathway
activation, is always co-localized with these three markers
of myofibroblasts.
And as therapeutic intervention, we tested the small molecule EGFR
inhibitor erlotinib right before emergence of HCC.
And we see that risk signature is improved in a dose-dependent
manner and tumor nodes are reduced in a dose-dependent
manner.And in the liver tissue, we see the
suppression of phosph EGFR along with the cell proliferation marker PCNA.
And in the isolated primary myofibroblasts from this animal, we see
the phosph EGFR is completely shut down, along with the suppression of downstream
oxaline.
Interestingly, which is not seen in ACC.
And also, we know that there is a very interesting PK property of the
compound, which is poorly uptake in the tumor tissue, tumor cell.
And if you look at the tumor reduction by size, we see the reduction of
overall tumor number. But if you look at the small nodule in the gray bar, this is
significantly reduced, but not for the larger tumor, suggesting this
compound mainly inhibiting the early stage of the
initiation of the cancer, but not the later stage progression of the cancer.
So with this, we did this phase one windows of opportunity
trial in cirrhosis patients undergoing elective liver surgery
for any type of liver tumor. And we did liver biopsy
before surgery, and then given the erlotinib at these three dose, which is
significantly lower compared to the approved therapeutic dose,
seven days. And then, patient got the resection.
This way, we have a pair liver tissue.
And for the primary endpoint, phosph EGFR suppression in liver tissue.
Secondary endpoint, risk signature modulation and safety.
The primary endpoint, phosph EGFR suppression was achieved at the lowest dose,
25 mg. This is a one-sixth dose of therapeutic dose.
Secondary endpoint, signature modulation observed at 50 mg or
higher. So again, in this bar plot, when the bar goes down, this is
an improvement of the risk level, which is seen in the higher dose,
50 or 75 mg,
with no adverse events. We see the only mild skin rash at the highest dose,
which is quickly going away after stopping the drug.
So, we picked the responder, non-responder from the phase one
trial, and they did a spatial profiling to confirm
if our hypothesis is true or not. So here is the
spatial profiling in the responder.
So here we have a pre-treatment biopsy and a post-treatment resection
tissue. Green is a hepatocyte, blue is a high fibrous area, pink
dot is a myofibroblast. And here you see the change the
proportion of the each cell types in the pre-treatment and post-treatment.
And we saw myofibroblast significantly reducing the signature
responder.
In a non-responder, we didn't see the same.
So basically, all cell types are still on the diagonal line, the proportion
unchanged.
And the number is reduced, and what about the pathway activation
status? So we checked the EGFR pathway gene set
modulation, which is, again, the orange is induction,
green is suppression. And we saw in the responder on the top row,
EGFR signature suppressed in the myofibroblast, which is not seen in the
non-responder. Seems to supporting our hypothesis.
Erlotinib inhibit EGFR signaling in myofibroblast that lead to the
improvement of the risk signature.
So with this, this is a phase two trial we are starting
as a part of the Liver Cancer Support Program, which we call the
ECHO-B trial, for the longer duration treatment, six months,
compared to placebo.
And the inhibition of the kinase
pathway is not the only way to target myofibroblast, according to
this Nature paper published some time ago.
So you can induce in the cellular senescence of the hepatic stellate
cell, myofibroblast can affect the liver cancer development or
suppression.
And our colleague, Brian Fuchs, found that green tea catechin,
epigalocatechin gallate or EGCG, can reduce proliferating
myofibroblast, as shown in the two color IF,
by inducing senescence in the myofibroblast,
significantly improving the clinical risk signature and reduce
the ACC nodule. Based on which, we got
an NIH grant to do this phase two trial to
test the EGCG, which we call CATCH-B trial, in the same design.
Statin has been suggested as a promising chemoprevention agent
by the countless clinical studies, and this is one of the latest
one done by my colleague, Wei Chan of Mass General Hospital.
In the more than 16,000 patients in the Mass General Brigham
Research Patient Data Registry, confirming that statin
users have roughly half ACC incidence over the 10
years follow-up. But again, if you want to confirm in a prospective trial,
you need more than 3,000 patients for 10 years.
So you might think that the surrogate biomarker approach may
rescue the situation. And first, we confirmed that one of the
lipostatins, atorvastatin, improved the risk biomarker,
likely because of attaching the additional carcinogenesis pathway compared
to the other statin, based on which this is a third chemoprevention trial
testing atorvastatin, which we call TOSS trial.
And by coincidence, NIDDK Liver Cirrhosis Network is
running this, another statin trial called SaveResQ trial.
And by chance, they are testing rosuvastatin, which is a hydrophilic statin,
and we had a chance to analyze both trial samples from
those trial. And we are hoping to compare the lipo versus
hydrophilic statin in the setting of prospective trial.
And we also found this clinical risk signature can be modeled in the cell culture
model done by Dr. Emil Kovatcheva and Dr.
Thomas Baumert, in which you can induce a clinical risk signature
by the clinical ATC etiology in which you can
test and screen the compounds.
And this is the latest
discovery, which found the next gen antipsychotic aripiprazole,
reduce inflammation, reduce fibrosis, and reduce carcinogenesis
through the serotonin receptors.
So to summarize, clinically validated cancer risk biomarker can refine
secondary prevention via improved risk stratification and
also the discovery and testing of clinical relevant new chemoprevention
strategy.Thanks for your attention, and happy to take any question.
Thank you, Professor Hoshida. So the floor is open for some questions.
Maybe I start with one. So what do you think of the role of
liquid biomarkers going forward for HCC?
Do you think there's a space there?
Yeah, definitely. That's one of the areas we are actively working on,
and I'd love to get your thought and possible collaboration.
And I think we can think about the many different type of biomolecule.
So one of our biomarker is serum proteome.
This can be regarded as a liquid, liver-based
measurement. And also the cfDNA can be utilized for many
different things, not only the structural variants, but also several
people are using the information by looking at the fragmentation pattern to
infer the gene expression levels and so forth.
So I think there is a huge potential.
Question.
Great talk. So you
explained the EGFR in myofibroblast is
critical, and you show the erlotinib
treatment in the early stage
tumor effective, but larger tumor
does not respond. So do you have any insight
why only smaller tumor are responsive to
erlotinib?
Yeah, sure. We think
this is not suppressing proliferation of a already
transformed neoplastic cell, but stopping the
much earlier stage, before transforming the
matured hepatocyte into the pre-neoplastic or neoplastic cells.
And indeed, erlotinib already tested as anticancer drug in a Phase
II trial, both failed.
And again, the PK study suggest neoplastic cell do
not uptake erlotinib comparing to the other fast generation EGFR
inhibitor.
Maybe a follow-up question on myofibroblast.
Do you think this is related to more the fatty liver disease,
or is a general phenomenon for cirrhosis-
Mm-hmm
... to liver cancer?
Yeah. I think another great question because with the single-cell
technology you
would talk about, now we know that there are many different subset
of myofibroblast or stellate cell, like a proliferative,
inflammatory, the vascular cell, and so
forth. So yeah, I guess it may be possible.
There is a slight difference in the nuance
according to the liver disease etiology or stage.
Yeah.
One more question. Yeah.
Thank you, professor. Very interesting talk.
Since you're interested in looking at very early-stage interventions,
I'm wondering if you have done any work to look
at the efficacy of the different treatments,
in HCC where there are different mutations.
So for example,
TERT mutations-
Hmm
... or looking at WNT pathway mutations. Is there a difference in the efficacy?
Yeah. Another great question. And yeah, I don't have the answer, but
that's definitely the something we should care about.
Seeing the
study, for example, the beta-catenin mutated
neoplastic cell can form the tumor under the specific
physiological conditions such as
certain hepatic metabolic zones, so on and so forth.
So,
yes, we need to get better understanding, what are the
paths for the
carcinogenesis tumor formation according to the different type
of genetic mutation, for example, TERT mutation or other
mutation or other somatic changes.
Thank you, professor.
Thank you.
One more question. Quick one.
Thank you, professor. Nice presentation.
I think there are some reports about hepatic stem cell,
the relationship between hepatic stem cell and
HCC development or HCC chem sensitivity.
So, if you have experience about this hepatic stemness
marker-
Hmm
...
do you have any opinion about this-
Mm-hmm
... stem cell?
Yeah. I think that this is another great point to think about.
And,
yeah, so with the recent study, we now know that it's more
complicated than we thought, and that cells can have a
plasticity,
going back to the stemness state or mature state, going back and forth.
And,
yeah, we also see that if you look at the different stemness markers, each
cell population behave very differently in a different tissue
environment, so on, so forth. So yeah, that's definitely the important
issue we need to sort out. And then maybe we learn from Dr.
Cho's presentation in a minute.
Thank you.
Thank you. With that, we'd like to thank you for the great presentation.
So I think from prevention, right now I would just focus on immune
microenvironment to bring you through across three different
therapy given to HCC patient, and with the aims of identifying
biomarkers, understand the mechanism, and hopefully, with some
potential therapeutic targets.
So I think myself and many in the field have
contributed a lot into this understanding of tumor immune
microenvironment of HCC. We know there are
several different types of immune cell that infiltrate to the liver, and
particularly, like I myself have a great interest in TReg cell.
We know that TReg cell and some of these tumor-associated macrophages,
they are often associated to poor prognosis in the patient
after resection.Some other immune cells, such as cytotoxic CD8 T
cells, they are more often related to good prognosis of the patient after
resection. With that in mind, we also know that
therapy is likely to change this immune microenvironment,
and with that, probably towards the better of the tumor microenvironment, therefore
the patient will respond to the therapy.
Another point is that we also believe that this immune system
is dynamic and systemic in nature, so sometimes we
believe that the peripheral biomarkers can be identified in the
blood if we chase the immune cells.
So I will show you several examples of this.
And why? Because liquid biomarkers are really convenient and it's
non-invasive in nature, so I think we believe there's a great potential to grow in
that area.
So one of the first therapy that I would like to talk about is actually
locoregional radiotherapy. So this is in collaboration with my
colleague, Professor Pier Chow, from National Cancer Singapore.
And this radiotherapy is actually given to patient with
intermediate HCC that's inoperable.
This therapy is given as a single dose, as a radiotherapy
directly into the liver tumor to the hepatic artery.
It has a very short half-life of around three days.
By seven days, the radioactivity is actually gone.
But when we see the response in the patient, we often see as a
delayed response of up to three to six months.
And when they respond, they usually show a sustained response.
So to a cancer immunologist like myself, we believe this is an immune
response to the therapy.
With that in mind, we actually collected the blood as well as the tissue before and
after radiotherapy in order to try to understand whether we can derive
any biomarkers or understand the mechanism.
So we analyzed this data using CyTOF and RNA sequencing.
If you do not know CyTOF, it's actually a high-dimensional
immunomonitoring platform where we can focus up to
41 protein immune markers, intracellular and the
surface.
So first of all, from our CyTOF data, so in a patient who responded
to Y90 after the therapy, we can see the enrichment of a whole
bunch of cytotoxic kind of immune cell.
So that includes the NK cell, NK killer, NKT
cell, as well as CD4 and CD8 T cell that are active in nature because
they express a whole bunch of activation marker, including CD69 and
granzyme B. However, in the clinically matched
control patient who are not treated, we often see the usual
Treg cell being enriched in the tumor microenvironment.
So that shows us that the Y90 can actually elicit an active immune
response. But what about biomarkers in the blood?
Because that's our true interest.
So in fact, we can actually identify CD8 T cell that express this
interesting chemokine receptor, CXCL6 and
CCR5, suggesting that they have the ability to home to the
tumor microenvironment.
So this is the biomarkers that only appear in the responder even before the
treatment is given, suggesting this kind of CD8 T cell will
identify the patient who will eventually respond to this
expensive Y90 radiotherapy.
So since we kind of hypothesized that they could home to the tumor
tissue, we went into the tissue, and we did the RNA sequencing,
and what we find is the patient who are responding to Y90, they actually
upregulate a whole bunch of immune-related pathways,
including T cell activation and antigen presenting pathway.
But more importantly, we saw this chemotaxis pathway, which is
our regulator in this patient who respond to Y90,
and lo and behold, we can find the chemokines that is actually attracting our
biomarkers from the blood. So these are the CXCL16 and
CCL5 that binds to CCR5 and CXCL6, a CD8
T cell from the blood. So we hypothesized that with this
tissue increasing chemokines, it created the chemokine
gradients where we can attract this CD8 T cell into the tumor microenvironment,
giving rise to actually the active
immune response to Y90.
So we believe this is a mechanism of response to a radiotherapy, so
not only the radioactivity kills the tumor cell, but the long-term
effect is actually the immune response to it.
And apart from this chemokine expressing CD8 T cell, we also find
another type of CD8 T cell that express PD-1 and TIM-3.
You may think that PD-1 and TIM-3 are exhaustion marker, but to us, we think
these are the prime T cell who actually could be responsible
to the tumor killing at the end. With that in mind, because they also express
PD-1, so we have this idea of combining radiotherapy with
anti-PD-1, together with my colleagues from National Cancer Center.
So we run a small trial on Asian patients with HCC, combining
Y90 with anti-PD-1.
So as true blue cancer immunologists, I think we are most interested in checkpoint
inhibitor because this is really the current mainstream in solid
tumor care, including in HCC. So you may also know that
anti-PD-1 is one of the first treatment immunotherapy given
to HCC patient as a monotherapy. However,
unfortunately, it actually has quite a modest response,
about 20%. And since this is a systemic therapy
given to the patient, anti-PD-1 also very often cause
this immune-related adverse effect.
So we think that this is actually a spectrum of the disease
outcome or therapy outcome because of the
anti-PD-1 therapy and the mechanism.
Since this is likely to be a systemic effect, again, we went into the
blood to kind of source for the biomarkers and understand the mechanism.
At the same time, we also collected the tissue, much like the Y90 therapy,
and then we analyzed them using CyTOF and this time, single cell RNA seq.
With that in mind, we actually wanted to understand how we can distinguish
between response and IRAE, and can we actually focus on the
common biomarkers that span across this distinct
kind of outcome from anti-PD-1, and to design a therapy
that could enhance response without the increase of
toxicity.So again, this work is by my
previous PhD student, Samuel Chua.
And by looking into our CyTOF data again, we are focusing on the
common immune biomarkers or immune cell that span across the
respond and IIAE. And fortunately, we are able to actually
identify two
immune cell that span across this continent.
And these are the CXCR3 positive CD8 T cell and the
HLA-DR high antigen presenting cell.
So first of all, we need to show that they're actually homing to the tumor
microenvironment. So if we trace them in the blood along the
therapy duration, comparing 10 weeks versus
six weeks after the checkpoint inhibitor, we can see this population
actually decrease from the blood, suggesting again they're disappearing somewhere,
homing somewhere to the tissue. We need the evidence to show
that, so we went into the tumor tissue, and we saw that only in
the responding patient, we don't see in the non-responding patient, they actually
out-regulate the chemokines that are able to bind to the
CXCR3 positive CD8 T cell. These are the CXCL9,
10, and 11, all three of them. At the same time, we see a whole
bunch of genes that is related to antigen presenting, which
is all the HLA related genes, suggesting
again, the antigen presenting cell are able to also home to the tumor
microenvironment.
We are not the only group describing this.
In fact, we saw this paper also from Cell in 2021,
where they do a meta-analysis across more than 1,000
patients treated with checkpoint inhibitor.
And what they found, the strongest biomarkers for respond is very similar to
what we found in HCC. So these are the CXCL9 again,
and then our CD8 T cell and the T cell information
signature. So these are the three key component for respond to
checkpoint inhibitor. So we think that this is likely the same mechanism
also in HCC.
And to confirm this, another study from Sandro Bruno's group published
in Journal of Hepatology also show that again, the importance of CD8 T
cell in the respond to checkpoint inhibitor, not so much the antigen
presenting cell.
So that leads us to wonder whether antigen presenting cell are really
truly one of the biomarkers spending respond in IIAE.
We need to venture into single cell RNA seq because despite CyTOF being
high dimensional, it has a limitation of up to only 41 markers.
With the single cell RNA seq, we went deeper into understanding the antigen
presenting cell that is related to respond versus
IIAE. What we found is that the cell that is related to
respond is actually CDC1. So these are the dendritic cell that is
able to present tumor antigens, so they are associated to respond, which makes
sense.
However, the one related to IIAE is actually CD14 positive
myeloid cell.
That actually rule out antigen presenting cell as the common immune cell that
span across respond and IIAE.
However, I think fortunately for us, we still have the CXCR3 positive CD8 T
cell. With that, we focus on this particular cell and trying to understand the
distinct signaling pathway or interaction pathway
and see whether we can actually distill the differences between respond versus
IIAE. And we found TNF pathway. So
we saw that TNF pathway that binds to TNF receptor two
is related to respond, whereas the one that bind to TNF receptor
one is related to toxicity or IIAE.
So we try to block these two different pathway to see whether we can
actually distinguish between respond or separate the effect of respond
from IIAE. Of course, we need to test this in the mouse model.
So with the liver cancer mouse model, we combine anti-PD-1 with anti-TNF
receptor one or receptor two and see if we can enhance the effect
of respond and distinguish between the toxicity.
As you can see here, an anti-TNF receptor two blockade, because this is
the one that related to respond. Once we block it, we absolutely see
no tumor at all in all our animals. So they tell us that if you
block this pathway related to respond, you enhance the respond.
So what about receptor one? Because it's related to toxicity.
So when we block it, we actually see enhanced toxicity, so it's much like the
respond kind of scenario. The enhanced
toxicity is shown by increased CD8 T cell infiltration to the
non-tumor part of the liver, which oftentimes we see as a
toxicity in the liver.
And this CD8 T cell also express CD69, but then they become
activated and resident.
What about receptor two? Because we thought receptor two is cleanly
associated to only respond. What we actually can see is that there is
no increase of CD8 T cell significantly compared to
anti-PD-1 alone, suggesting that if we apply this
therapy in combination with anti-PD-1, TNR receptor two
is able to enhance the respond without the increase of IIAE.
And many people ask, so what is the mechanism of TNF receptor two?
So in our same study, we actually show that TNF receptor two,
the receptor itself is expressed on several immune cell that is
mainly immunosuppressive in nature.
That includes the Treg cell and the tumor associated macrophages.
So when you block this TNF receptor two in the tumor microenvironment, you
actually reduce the immunosuppressive function of this immune cell, thereby
enhancing the anti-tumor immune response.
Some other people also show that TNF receptor two can be expressed on the tumor
cell itself. When you block it, you actually slow down the tumor progression and
metastasis. So it makes sense that this could be a good
potential combination immunotherapy to be given to
anti-PD-1 and enhance the response without the increase of
toxicity. But the last treatment I would really like
to talk about because you may know that now in the
HCC, in the clinical setting, the standard of care is actually
combination immunotherapy because immunotherapy checkpoint by
anti-PD-1 alone doesn't really work very wellWell, in
atezolizumab, which is a combination of anti-PD-1 with
anti-VEGF-A, we are seeing good response in the patient, even though
about 20% or 30%.
Again, still many patients are resistant to this therapy.
So we would really like to understand the mechanism.
And given that anti-VEGF-A is actually the local
anti-angiogenesis agent, so we focus really on
the tissue microenvironment itself using spatial transcriptomics
to try to really understand the cell-cell interaction within the
tumor microenvironment that tell us why certain patients do not respond to
this therapy.
At the same time, you may notice that we are from a tiny island in Singapore,
so our cohort are usually very small.
So I really validate our findings by
collaboration across the group. And so for this particular study,
we work with the Japanese and the Belgian collaborators
who provide the validation data. Of course, last but not least, we need
a mouse model to prove the mechanism.
With the interest of time, I will just focus on the key findings from this
particular study, which is currently still under revision.
We found that patients who are resistant to atezolizumab is actually driven by
this crosstalk between macrophages and endothelial cell.
You may appreciate from these findings here, the non-responding patient,
you can actually see the endothelial cells, which is a blood vessel
cell marked by CD31 in red color here, and
the cross interaction between them with the
macrophages marked by the cyan color CD68 population.
So almost in some cases, they are intertwined with one another, suggesting they are
doing something
to the resistance to this therapy.
If you measure the distance, you can also see that they are very close by with one
another in the non-responding patient.
And what we really found, what they're doing when they interact with one another is
actually to induce this alternative angiogenesis pathway.
So anti-VEGF is the angiogenesis agent, but you can see that in the
non-responding patient, they are not able to block the
angiogenesis. In fact, the non-responding patient upregulate
angiogenesis by the anti-VEGF independent pathway, which
is an alternative angiogenesis pathway.
So in this particular study, we found it's actually driven by macrophages and
endothelial cell crosstalk and through the integrin pathway.
So to conclude with just a simple cartoon, we see that in non-responding
patient, the macrophages and endothelial cell, they're in cross-contact with one
another, and this drives the integrin pathway and giving
rise to the non-respond to atezolizumab.
In the animal model, we show that if we block this integrin pathway,
we are able to enhance the response to atezolizumab.
So as a grand conclusion, because I show you three different therapy
given to HCC patient, you can appreciate the biomarkers and the
mechanisms are distinct in nature.
So in the Y90 radiotherapy, we saw the CD8 T cell homing to the
tumor microenvironment that could actually give rise to the response as
our important biomarkers.
In the anti-PD-1 checkpoint inhibitor study, we found that CXCR3
positive CD8 T cell as an important biomarkers.
And understanding the biology, we are able to actually propose anti-TNF
receptor 2 in combination with anti-PD-1 as a potential
combination therapy to enhance the response without the increase of IRE.
For resistant to atezolizumab, what we found is that the interaction between
macrophages and endothelial cell is a key mechanism to
drive alternative angiogenesis in the non-responding
patient.
With that, I think I would like to end with this timely or untimely
analogy. So we think that our strategy is much like a spy network,
where we receive the signal, we analyze them deeply, and
then we come up with a strategy to tackle this HCC patient.
And different treatment will give rise to different kind of resistant mechanism
that we can actually make use of this information to design combination
therapy.
Last but not least, I would like to thank my team,
especially those who work on this project,
Yunhua, Samuel, and Otsuka,
and my local collaborator, particularly Professor Pier Chow and
Dr. David Tai, who provided the patient to us to
analyze. My other local collaborators, and especially
thankful to all my overseas collaborators who provided us with
validation cohorts. And we are very open to collaboration.
And these are my funding information.
And before I end, I would just like to invite you to
join us at ILCA Annual Conference, so ILCA stand for International Cancer
Association. This year in September, we will be in Brussels,
so I will really welcome you to join us.
And thank you for your attention. Would love to take any questions.
Sharing my cell.
Great talk.
Thank you.
So really enjoy your talk, and you show that the endothelial cell
and the macrophage interaction through integrin signal
will block those anti-VEGF therapy and
angiogenesis. My question is, how does
integrin signal pathway is involved to
block those anti-VEGF therapy for
angiogenesis?
Thank you for your question. So in fact, what we saw is that by interaction
between macrophages and endothelial cell, it actually drives
integrin pathway. And integrin pathway itself has been shown that it
can be an angiogenesis pathway. It's alternative angiogenesis.
So from our patient data, after the therapy, we see the
non-responding patient who are resistant to the
therapy to actually enhance this angiogenesis pathway, and mainly by this
integrin signaling.Thank you.
Thank you very much, Verena.
I would have a question regarding the first part of your talk,
with the Y90 part.
Mm-hmm.
So as a clinician, so we are now doing
combination with Y90 and immunotherapy, but one of the big question
we have is should we propose immunotherapy
before-
Oh.
-starting Y90 or putting after?
Do you have any data or maybe some-
That's a great question that I get asked very often.
So what we believe is after Y90. There are several reason
why this is so, because also from our own data.
After Y90, you have tumor killing.
So we release some of this antigen, which also drive increase in
PD-1. We also, in our own data, we show post-therapy, there's
more PD-1 coming in, therefore, you block the anti-PD-1.
In fact, the timing of it is also very strategic.
We believe at least one month after Y90.
You cannot give it too early because you need this PD-1 to actually appear
because they are important for the active immune response. That's what we believe.
And regarding the type of treatments, should it be anti
PD-L1, anti CLTA-4, maybe TKI? I don't
know.
From our data, we believe the anti PD-1 could be one of the best strategy,
but let's see.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yep.
I have a few questions regarding the T cell response.
So
just looking at the data from the Y90 experiments as well as the subsequent
one,
actually, the definition of your memory subsets overlap
somewhat with the rest of the memory subset.
So the question really is,
are the responses that you're seeing as a result of de novo
priming of T cells and then their subsequent differentiation into those subsets,
or is this the re-energization of an already
present liver TRM subset?
Hmm.
Yeah, I think for the second experiment, you have both peripheral blood
and
liver data, but I don't think you have the TCR clone data that would really be
helpful.
Yeah, so we don't do TCR cloning data because
HCC in the first place, they are very heterogeneous, even intra-tumorally.
So by chasing down the TCR clonality, we think that
will be a huge mess to kind of decipher the different
effect. But having said that, I think the different T cell you're asking whether
they are resident T cell that is probably reprogrammed, reactivated, or it's
more like the systemic T cell that is recruited.
So we actually like to believe both are important, I mean, from
ourself and other people's data. But what I have described in the first
two talks is mainly the T cell from the blood that
express the chemokine receptor. So with that receptor, if you go
down to the tissue level, you see the increase of this chemokine that suggests
they could actually home to the tumor microenvironment.
So in that sense, since we're chasing liquid biomarkers in the
blood, so we are focusing on this particular T cell subset that
home to the tumor microenvironment, but not discounting the importance
of already present T cell in the tumor microenvironment.
I personally believe both are important.
I mean, CXCR6, CCR5, these are also expressed by in
situ primed liver T cells and-
Yeah. But we saw it in the blood, so that's the reason why we
believe they're also home from the blood.
Okay.
Hi. I have two questions. So the first one
for the macrophage and endothelial cell crosstalk,
because we know that macrophage can also
secrete the VEGF. So do you think...
Have you measuring the level of VEGF, and do you think that
can be potential mechanism underlie the crosstalk
between the macrophage and the endothelial cell?
Yeah. So VEGF, this one of our focus as well.
So in the non-responding patient, indeed, they are also increased.
But we saw that the integrin pathway is most important in this
crosstalk because we look at cell-cell interaction and their signaling pathway-
Right
... between them. So in the non-responding patient, if you compare with the
responding patient-
Mm-hmm
... what we see is that this enhance integrin as an important mechanism of
escape.
Yeah.
Yeah. And then the second one is,
I remember you, it might be wrong, maybe I remember wrong, but you say
that when you take a look between the patient that have
adverse event and then those that respond to the
PD-1, those adverse event have
more CD14 cell, and then those
respond is more-
DC1.
Yes, DC1.
Because can you specify which CD14 population did you
take into? Which cell type specific is that?
Because CDC2 is also CD14 positive,
and then it was known to secrete a lot of CXCL9,
CXCL10 to bring in the CXCL13 T cell in.
So could that be the population of CDC2?
Okay. So in the respond, it's actually CDC1 that is
related to this.
No, I'm asking that can the CD14-
The CD14.
... is the CDC2.
So the CD14, from what we see in the single cell RNA seq data, they
are truly myeloid population, so they're not DC.
So we confirm it's not CDC.
It's just like monocyte, like circulating monocyte.
Monocyte.
Okay.
Yeah. It's mainly monocyte.
Thank you.
Thank you for your question.
So I guess with the interest of time... Oh, please.
Seeing that little more time, yeah, just a quick question.
So I saw you talk about antigen-presenting cells associated,
but I felt you didn't talk much in detail.
So I wonder
how it can
explain at least partially for the distinction between the T cell
receptor one versus two activation or
the other response or no response, maybe
according to the difference in the neoantigen profile or something or?
So antigen-presenting cell is really important.
For the particular study that I mentioned, it's because we want to find the common
immune cell, which is the T cell in that case.
So antigen-presenting cell, because they are quite kind of distinct in nature,
the one related to respond and IIE, therefore we
didn't chase down the route because you need to come up with different strategy if
you want to target two different cell.
So that's the reason why we didn't kind of follow up on that.
But not discounting the fact that I think antigen-presenting cell plays a very
important role in respond. So we have other project currently ongoing,
focusing more on the antigen-presenting cell.
Thank you.
Thank you. So with that, I think I end my talk, and I
would now like to invite our third speaker.
Manon Allaire.
I think maybe you can introduce your own institute because it's in French and it's
a little bit difficult for me to... Okay.
But now we will focus on personalized care in HCC. Please, Dr.
Manon.
Thank you very much, Valerie, and it's really a great pleasure for me to be here
today. So my name is Manon Allaire.
I'm working in Paris. I'm mostly clinician, but I'm doing
also research. And so I'm responsible of the liver tumor
unit in La Pitié Salpêtrière in Paris, and I'm working with
Jean-Pierre Coutin, the Centre de Recherche des Cordeliers, which is an Inserm
unit in Paris.
So here are my disclosure.
And so for today, I will try to discuss in this
talk about some strategy to improve the outcome of
our patients, and I will more focus on
patient with advanced HCC for whom immunotherapies
now the new standard of care. Professor Xu just
showed you. And so the first part of my talk,
I will
discuss about some predictive markers of response
for immunotherapy. So as a clinician, what I would like is
to be able to propose the good treatment to my patient,
and this is something we looked at in my lab, and we succeeded to
identify a potential new signature that I will show you
today. And then I will also discuss about the
importance of preserving liver function, because when we are treating
HCC patient, we have to consider that the majority of our
patient will also present cirrhosis at the same time.
And so we really need to be careful on this liver function to screen,
for example, for portal hypertension because we know that if you have portal
hypertension, this can lead to liver decompensation,
such as ascites, bleeding, or hepatic
encephalopathy. And we know that this can directly
impact the prognosis for our patient, but also can
prevent them to have access to further treatment.
So this point is really critical when we are taking care of
HCC patient. And for the last part of my talk, I will
present you a new approaches we are currently developing in France
with the aim of proposing drugs to target some
specific genomic alteration identified within the
tumor.
So let's move with the first part. So here
are the result of a project we started some years ago with Jean-Pierre
Coutin in my lab with the help of Isabelle and Amna.
And we decided to focus on blood like
Valerie did,
in her patient treated with atezolizumab bevacizumab.
In the literature, if you have a look, we already have some data
that allowed us to
identify some immune cell that can predict response to
atezo-bev and this was mostly done by the team of Professor
Hovet that mostly focus on tumor biopsy.
But when we started to discuss this project with Jean-Pierre,
my problem that it was not so easy for me to have tumor
biopsy for each patient treated with atezo-bev.
And that's why we also decided to work on blood,
and we included prospectively 31 HCC patient treated with
atezo-bev. And if you have a look to the characteristic of the population,
it's quite usual with what we are seeing in France.
And we perform facts analysis, and we look at
some different immune cell type. And quite
surprisingly, what we identify is that an higher
level of gamma delta T cell at baseline was
associated with disease control at imaging at six
months, meaning complete response, partial response, and
also stable disease. And this data were also
confirmed when we perform our analysis of the
progression-free survival, the PFS, and you can see here that
it was significantly higher in patient who presented
more gamma delta T cells at baselineAnd so
we decided to focus on this cell type population, and indeed they were quite
interesting. Why? Because these gamma delta T cell, they have the
capacity of secreting interferon gamma, for example, but
also they can secrete perforin and granzymes, so they seem like
interesting cell type population as
anti-tumor cells. And so we have these
results in the blood, but our next question was, but
is it the same within the tumor biopsy, the
tumor? And what we did is that we took
advantages of the data available from the
IMbrave 150 trial that Valérie also used,
that you can have access quite easily.
And so you have all this RNA sequencing data
which belong to the trial, and the advantage that you can
have access to patient treated with atezo bev, but also with sorafenib.
And so what we did is that we look at this data, and we
decided to look at what was going on with
what we call the gamma delta T cell signatures.
And what you can see here in that in the patient with an high
gamma delta T cell signatures, meaning a lot of gamma delta T
cells within the tumor, this was associated
with better response at imaging, but also
significant better PFS and overall survival.
And what is interesting to notice also on this slide is that when we
did the same for the patient treated with sorafenib, you can
see that the result were totally different, and we did not
observed any difference in the outcome of the patient.
And so we thought that maybe we have something, a new signature
using these gamma delta T cells, but we were speaking about a
treatment with atezolizumab and bevacizumab.
And so after, the next step was to look at some
tumor biopsy from colorectal cancer patient treated with
immunotherapy, and we did the same.
We look at these gamma delta T cell signatures, and you can see that
here it was the same. For the patient with an high gamma delta
T cell signatures, PFS and OS was better.
So maybe we have something new here, a new signature that can
predict response to immunotherapy.
And so then the next question was
to understand the mechanism. And so we went back to our blood
test, and we were lucky because we had the ability to
compare blood test data between baseline and
before the second infusion of atezo bev.
And we perform a blood RNA sequencing, and
we compare the result according to the group of patient who
responded to treatment and the one who progressed.
And you can see that the transcriptomic profile was quite different
between the two group. And when we went more in detail into the
result of this analysis, what we noticed is that
the responder patient presented an upregulation
on some pathway related to interferon alpha and gamma response,
but also an higher gamma delta T cells signature once
again. And so then we also performed some
cytokines analysis within the blood to see if
we have indeed this type of result, and we also observed
that
interferon gamma level was higher at baseline in
patient who responded to treatment.
So the next step of this project are right now ongoing, and
so we want to go a bit further, and we will really look at
the different sub-cell type of gamma delta T
cells because we know that you can have the type one, type two, and
also some of them can progress and produce IL-17
at one point. So this analysis we are currently performing.
And also we want to look at the signatures in other
combination of treatment we are
using right now for patient with advanced HCC, such
as the dual combination of immunotherapy.
So then I will move to the next part of my talks, which
will be really focused on the cirrhosis and the underlying
liver disease.
So right now we have more and more data regarding
this treatment with atezo bev in the literature, where
were data that confirm the result of the phase three
trial, such as this multicentric prospective
French cohort that included 180
patient treated with atezo bev,
with more severe patient. Because in France, what you have to know is that
the majority of our patient present alcohol-related
cirrhosis with more severe cirrhosis and a lot of portal
hypertension, about half of our patient.
So it's a bit different to the population which was included in the phase three
trial. And we have really interesting result because you can see that here,
the survival, the median overall survival was 23 months.
But what is interesting to notice here is that when we
try to identify some predictive factors associated with
mortality, what we identify were not HCC
features, but it was features related to the underlying liver
disease, and more specifically, the presence of portal
hypertension. And this is really important because
when you have portal hypertension, this can lead to liver
decompensation, ascitis, bleeding, hepatic
encephalopathy, and this can clearly impact the
prognostic of your patient treated with immunotherapy.
And this was clearly demonstrated in this study
with individual data from the IMbrave 150 trial that
included 400 patient, and you can see that the liver
decompensation occur as a first event in
about 30% of the patient. And this was
associated with an higher mortality with a median
overall survival of six months compared to 24 in patient
without any decompensation or RTC progression.So this
is really an important feature we need to take into account.
And in this context, so this is a work we
perform in my hospital with Professor Dominique Tabut, and also
in collaboration with the team of Jacob Carter and Asia
Rabasco in Germany, in Dresden, in which we
included our patients in Paris treated with atezo-bev,
about 500 patients. You can see here that we
have more severe patients, about 60% with
varices, meaning portal hypertension, and 29% of
patients with decompensated cirrhosis.
And so what we did is that we took these patients with the usual
clinical biological data. But what is
original in this study is that we took the whole
CT of the patients, and we analyzed
through artificial intelligence
models, the impact of this CT
imaging
on to predict portal hypertension at the beginning, but
also liver decompensation. And all this
analysis were performed by Asia. And what did we
observe is that in this cohort of patients, you can see that the rate of
liver decompensation was 30% at one year, which is
quite high, and it was indeed associated with an
increased mortality. And so what is
interesting is that Asia performs this analysis and he
identifies some clinical and biological data associated
to this liver decompensation, quite usual one, presented
for societies of splenomegaly. But he
succeeded to create a new model, a new foundation model,
which he called HepatoSAJ CT model.
And you can see here that this model, based only on the
baseline CT of the patient, succeeded to
clearly differentiate two group of patient, one with
an high risk of liver decompensation and the other one with low
risk. And he also compared the performance of this
artificial intelligence model compared to what we are used
to do with clinical and biological data, and the performance of this
model was clearly better to the other one.
So this is something new, quite simple.
For the moment, it's still not used in clinical practice, but maybe
things will change
within the next years. But the next step of this project is to
see if we propose beta blockers, non-selective
beta blockers in this population of high-risk patients.
Does this allow to reduce the risk of liver decompensation
and improve the survival? Because this treatment by beta
blockers are usually proposed in patient with cirrhosis and
without HCC to reduce liver decompensation and
improve
survival.
And so now I will move to the last part of my
talk, and this will be a bit different.
I will be discussing now about molecular biology, let's
say, about HCC. And so we all know that
HCC is a unique combination of somatic genetic alteration
that will lead to HCC occurrence, as we discussed before,
but also to
the advancements of the disease. And now we have quite
a good knowledge of all the landscape of all this
mutation. And the team of Jessica Zucman-Rossi and
Jean Charlot clearly worked on
all this topic and allowed us to have this really nice
molecular classification. But the next step now is
to try to propose maybe some drugs
directly that can target this
specific genetic mutation. And this is currently a big
program that is running in France, in the French Medicine Genomic
program.
And in this program, you can include all your patient
with a cancer, whatever the type.
But you need to have a biopsy that can benefit from a
large molecular analysis. And so after, when you
have the result, the patient is discussed in a tumor board, and then they
go back to you, and they say, "Maybe you could try this drug,
and we will see what is going on." And so this is a large program.
But regarding the liver part,
currently, Jean Charlot and Claudia Company were in charge
of the analysis, and they just published some weeks ago
a paper with the first data of this
cohort with
primary liver tumor. And you can see that they included
120 patients. Among them, 103
patients had molecular data which were
analyzable. And if you have a look to the characteristic
of this patient, you can see that the majority of them presented with HCC,
67%, 20%
cholangiocarcinoma, and about 8% with mixed form
hepatocholangiocarcinoma. And if you have a look to the characteristic of the
population here, also it's quite similar to what we are seeing in France,
according to the type of the tumor.
But the relevant information here is that more
than 20% of the patients included in this
program already benefited from at least two line
of systemic treatment. This mean that this patient,
when they were included, presented already an advanced
disease.And so among these
103 patients, 67 of them, so
65%, presented with at least one
targetable genetic alteration. And these
alterations were then divided according to the ESCAT
classification, so the ESMO scale for clinical
actionability of molecular targets.
For example, ESCAT one means that the drug is already available,
and you can use it quite easily. I'm thinking, for example, of a
patient with a MET amplification that you can propose cabozantinib.
ESCAT two refers to drugs that are currently
under
investigation in trial, for example.
ESCAT three means that the drug is currently
used in another cancer, but not in the setting
of liver tumor, for example. And for ESCAT four, this
refers to drugs that are
mostly, for example, still at the preclinical
states.
And what you can see here is that
the majority of the ESCAT mutations which were
observed were belonging to the ESCAT
three and four classification, especially for HCC
patients, as you can see here.
And so among these 67 patients,
only 32 of them
were treated with this target therapy.
And you can see here on this slide the type of treatment which
was proposed according to the mutation observed, and also the
response that was observed at imaging, and also the
duration of treatment. But if we want to summarize,
among these patients, 32% of them presented a disease
control. And for the
majority of cases, it was related to patients with
cholangiocarcinoma and mixed hepatocholangiocarcinoma.
And this disease control was associated with a
better PFS, as you can see here, which was 12
months compared to two months for patients with progressive
disease. And so now the program is still going on.
So they are trying to include more and more patients.
And also now what we are doing is we try to propose
this program even before starting the first line of treatment,
because this analysis also takes time, sometimes two to three months.
So we are trying to already anticipate what
will happen for the patient, and this program is more and more
used in France.
And so to finish my talk, I will finish with this
slide
about the future of tumor boards,
because all that we are discussing today, finally, is to improve the
outcome of our patients. So I'm a clinician.
I'm leading the tumor board in my hospital.
And so every week when we are discussing, for sure, we have all this
clinical biological imaging data.
But sometimes when I have to take a decision, I think that maybe some
data are missing regarding all the work we are seeing right now with
the molecular approach, but also the immune cells approach, as it was
presented by Professor Shu. And also, for me, the underlying liver
function and all these parameters are really important.
So we hope that within the next year, we will have all this data,
and maybe also artificial intelligence will help us at one
point to propose a good treatment.
With all the talk we are here in this conference,
I think it's probably the future
of these approaches. But as I'm often discussing with
my friends who are working with artificial intelligence, we also need to
add the patient point of view here.
And also, this is from my advocacy part, which is really important for
me. So I would like to thank you for your attention, and for sure, I will
thank you also, all my team, because without them, I won't be here
today. And this is really a work of collaboration,
and I will be happy to take some questions.
Thank you.
Thank you for the great talk. I think you end really well with a bright future for
HCC, hopefully with AI help. Yeah.
So any questions?
Hi, I'm Li Chun Liu from NTHU, Taiwan.
About the gamma delta T cells, is it more important,
the level of these cells in serum or in tumor?
And is it possible that it's correlated with
prognosis but not necessarily predictive?
Because in your EMBRACE-Seraphine cohort, we also see a
little bit trend-
Yeah.
Of good prognosis with those high
gamma delta T cells. Yeah.
Sure. Thank you very much for your question.
So unfortunately, what is missing for us now is that I don't
have, for the same patient, what is going on in the blood and within the tumor at
the same time. And this is something we are currently working on, and we are
building a new cohort to be able to answer this question.
And for sure, I totally agree with you.
I'm
discussing about potential predictive factors of response.
But indeed, most of the data I just showed you were related
to PFS and survival.
So for the moment, we are in between.
But what we also are doing, for example, in
the molecular tumor board,
that for one of my patients some weeks ago, we were thinking about
rechallenging her with immunotherapy after a
fourth line. And we looked at
some immune signatures, and also we used these gamma delta T cell
signatures to help us with the
decision. So we decided to put her again
under immunotherapy, and we will see what is going on with that.
ButThese are some data we are starting to see and to
discuss how we can use it in clinical practice.
Next question.
Hi, I have two questions. The first is a follow-up on the gamma delta T cells.
So I think you presented data showing that,
possibly gamma delta-derived interferon gamma could be one of the drivers, yes?
But I'm sure you're well aware that there's at least three other major sources
of interferon gamma.
Exactly.
Plus, gamma delta T cells also have another important role as APCs.
Mm-hmm.
So do you have other data that perhaps differentiates the relative
contribution of either role?
Well, for the moment, unfortunately not, because these are really preliminary
data I showed today. But you're right, we are performing now
really more analysis with more markers
or so to better identify them and also to
better identify the dialogue between these cells
with also the other cells and also with the Treg.
Because we know also that at some point, gamma delta T cells, when they change a
bit of the phenotype, they can act as immunosuppressive
also within the microenvironment.
So for the moment, it's just preliminary data, but I hope maybe next
year I will provide you more things.
Thank you. The other question pertains to the use of your
imaging-based AI to
perhaps stratify patients. You mentioned that you already got an
AUC of 84%, something like that, just by imaging alone?
Yep.
If you combine that with the data on liver function that you
already collect for Child-Pugh scoring-
Yeah
... can you improve that?
No. Well, thank you very much for your question.
So this is something we look at with Assir and Jacob,
and unfortunately, it does not help to
really
improve. Why? Because in the clinical model,
what Assir found is ascitis and splenomegaly,
but this is something you can find finally on your CT scan.
Mm-hmm.
And unfortunately, we did not observe some,
for example, biological or other thing that could help us to predict
this. So for the moment, it's more relevant with the
CT,
but I think because the clinical data we identify are
overlapping with what you can see on the CT.
Thank you.
Maybe I want to ask a question or comment.
I'm really impressed with the program in France right now, looking at the
different genetic mutation and coming up with targeted therapy.
I think that's a great effort. But we all know that HCC have a
big problem with targeted therapy with resistant.
So what are your views on that? And do you think about combination, like with
immunotherapy for your system?
Yeah. Thank you very much. Indeed, this is a big problem, and
we know also that most of the time, our patient, they present various mutation at
the same time.
And so what Jean-Charles is doing is that they also
are looking really at the arena analysis
to see which mutation, which pathway seem
really upregulated, let's say, and they also choose the
drug according to these results. But you're right.
For the moment, they are mostly testing just one drug.
I think it's also more easier to have data
regarding the efficacy.
But probably with time, they will try to propose combination
approaches. And the idea also is that to perform a
new biopsy also after progression, so they can also compare what is
going on with the treatment.
So we can move along with time.
Exactly.
If the patient resist. Okay. If there's no further question.
Yes, please.
Yeah. Thanks for sharing the great
ongoing works in your program.
For the genomic medicine part, I have two questions.
The first is the genomic medicine part.
So are you doing the matching of the mutation and the drug
within the fixed set of drugs or approved drug
or outside approved drug?
Well-
And also, how do you accommodate the newly approved drugs and so forth?
Sure. So what I did not say that in this molecular tumor board, you have a lot of
different specialists from different oncological field
and also
people who are doing phase one or phase two trial.
So within this discussion, it's
also inclusion into trial are discussed.
So sometimes they say, "Okay, let's go to this center where this trial is
open so you can test also this new drug." So it's
really open. What I mean is that it's drug that we can have access, drug
that can be prescribed for other
treatment, but also
trial which are currently available in France.
And also according to the city where the patient is living.
But for the moment, this is mostly in Paris, I have to say, but
they are trying to increase the program
in whole France.
I see. It's basically the open-
Yeah
... setting. So yeah, technically, I wonder if it's
kind of
restricted or controlled for the statistical power
aspect.
This a really good question. I think it's really controlled, but
unfortunately, I'm not really part of the analysis.
I know that they have a big team, really dedicated and specialized in this type
of analysis. And Jean-Charles also was
working a lot on these all approaches and molecular mutation,
is always checking also the results.
So I think yes, it's really well controlled, I hope.
I see.
Okay. Can I ask another question for the decompensation prediction?
SoDo you see any particular
decompensation events like variceal bleeding over
peritonitis or something, or if you see the difference in the predictive
factor?
Well, so in the definition we included, so
all three main liver decompensation definition, meaning
variceal bleeding, ascitis, and hepatic encephalopathy.
As here, look at more in detail into
the different type of decompensation.
But unfortunately, the amount of the patient were a bit
low, so it was not able to really perform accurate,
let's say, artificial intelligence analysis because of the low number of patient.
But what we are seeing in practice is most of the time the patients start with
ascitis and bled some weeks after,
hepatic encephalopathy, and after, well, it's really bad.
But,
yeah, unfortunately, we did not have the power, let's say,
to perform really accurate
sub-analysis.
I see. Thank you.
Thank you. So I think for the interest of time, I will just say a
few words for closing, and I would like to thank the speaker first,
Ala.
And so I would thank all my speakers today, and I think great talks
and insightful discussion as well.
So I would just like to close by saying HCC is a really complex
disease, very highly heterogeneous.
We just spoke about different etiology as well across the continent,
like from Asia is mainly hepatitis B, and in United States
we see some more hepatitis C sometimes.
And in Europe we have alcohol-related
cases. So I think sometimes I feel like we are even talking about different
disease. The underlying disease is so important, and therefore I think
to close this session, I would really like to say to treat liver cancer better,
we really need to look at the disease continent, from the underlying
disease as well as to HCC for personalized care.
And also we need to work across the group more with one another because
they are so different, so we can learn from one another.
With that, I will close this session and thank you very much for staying to the
end.